nicolas partie vous êtes considéré comme
une star de l'art contemporain et on va
beaucoup parler de vos cours des
prochains mois à montréal pourquoi c'est
parce que vous avez exposé ici même au
musée des beaux-arts de montréal de
février à octobre 2022 et puis bon pour
la petite histoire pour ceux qui vous
connaissent pas vous êtes né en 1980 à
lausanne en suisse est pour vous tout a
commencé avec l'amour du graffiti si
vous étiez gras fort explications oui
tout à fait en fait j'ai commencé à
faire des greffes à l'âge de 11 ans à
lausanne j'habitais dans un petit
village à côté de lausanne au bord du
lac et en fait quand j'étais petit
j'aimais beaucoup les bêtises et le
dessin et la peinture et en fait ça
quand je suis devenu un peu plus grand
adolescent j'ai j'ai essayé de mélanger
les deux donc le parfait mélange entre
les bêtises mon amour à la passion de
l'art c'était de faire des graphes
revenons à cette exposition au musée des
beaux-arts vous avez complètement
transformé le vieil édifice avec avec
vos oeuvres qu'est-ce qui est venu vous
chercher vous dans le projet
effectivement l'espace en lui-même m'a
énormément influencé c'est un espace
classique absolument merveilleux et
fantastique et des détails
architecturaux la série de salles les
différentes perspectives sont vraiment
incroyables à utiliser donc ça a
vraiment été une énorme chance est un
plaisir
extraordinaire de travailler avec cet
espace vous attrape en plein travail
parce que dans la pièce d'à côté vous
effectuez une immense murale et c'est
une pure allant pastel qui votre médium
de prédilection en 2022 le pastel
pourquoi le passé l'ont fait souffler un
peu de projets avec à cause de son
histoire particulière qui qui se passe
au xviiie siècle et en fait c'était un
médium qui était hennion étudié par les
femmes en fait parce qu en fait vu
qu'ils étaient faits en bateau on
pouvait le faire à la maison à l'époque
au xviie siècle il ya la peinture à
l'huile de mon atelier on a fabriqué la
peinture elle n'existe pas en tube est
en fait le pastel devient extrêmement
populaire pour le pour les femmes n'ont
pas le droit d'aller à l'académie d'air
est en fait la révolution révolution
française il ya un espèce de backlash
énorme parce que c'est un mouvement
quand même très masculin est en fait
très conservateur artistiquement
culturellement par rapport au mouvement
rococo cas effectivement cadors le
pastel et ça vraiment ça donne un frein
et sakassou face à cette évolution du
médium est presse depuis ce moment là en
fait le médium souffre toujours de ceux
de sept décès après ricky sont plutôt
liées à la moby comme ça quelque chose
de pas sérieux eux-mêmes à des couleurs
un petit peu frivole tout ça alors qu'en
fait c'est évidemment un médium
extraordinaire qui est des couleurs très
pétantes ken universalité que très
versatile en fait dans une utilisation
vous avez un vif intérêt pour l'histoire
de l'art visiblement vous êtes inspiré
par georgia o'keefe la peintre
américaine mais aussi on y reçoit un
petit peu de de picasso dans votre
travail un peu de dali tout ça en même
temps qu'est ce qui vous intéresse
autant dans le passé pour mieux voir le
futur ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup dans
l'air c'est justement sa capacité à
travers traversé le temps et à voyager
dans le temps en fait une oeuvre moderne
et jamais contemporaine ou anciennes en
fait d'un renard a toujours de qualité
peut traverser le temps et on peut voir
un peu toujours un sujet en fait
présent dans une oeuvre d'art qui a été
créée en fait dans le passé d'ailleurs
c'est un des thèmes de l'exposition
c'est de revisiter
l'idée du paysage est né d'une relation
à la nature avec des peintures qui sont
des fois complètement en guinée
anachronique par rapport au monde dans
lequel on vit mais là contrairement la
science typiquement nous permet en fait
de vraiment de voyager dans le temps de
se retrouver face à des objets qu'on
peut vraiment avoir des interrogations
très très courante est très
contemporaine avec des objets qui sont
très anciens en fouillant dans votre
catalogue j'ai vraiment été interpellé
par le regard de vos personnages qu'est
ce qu'il veut dire pour moi en fait ils
sont un petit peu là ils ont le regard
un peu d'une peut-être d'un portrait qu
effectivement perdus dans l'espace en
fait des fois je les jeux les identifie
comme on enfile 3 la couche de
maquillage qui rassure une personne
c'est comme si en fait là vraiment là
c'était la surface d'un visage qui nous
regardaient pas l'intérieur du visage on
en fait on est un peu traverser mais ça
ça ne traverse un peu comme si on était
transparent fantômes et quelque chose
d'un petit peu effectivement énigmatique
qui fait presque un peu peur à la
manière de ces portraits que sur
instagram avec des filtres qui nous
regardent on sait plus trop si c'est des
vrais personne ou des personnes
complètement digital donc j'essaye un
peut-être un peu d'avoir ce type
d'interaction avec les portraits vos
oeuvres valent leur pesant d'or
d'ailleurs trois millions de dollars
pour une de vos toiles chez christie's à
l'automne dernier comment vous vivez ce
rapport à l'argent
que je le vis bien dans ce sens que
ça me permet de vivre aussi une vie qui
est agréable c'est pratique c'est jamais
facile pour un artiste de de se soucier
constamment de payer son atelier de paix
le matériel d'avoir un autre travail à
côté de son travail d'artiste donc c'est
clair que de vendre des tableaux permet
en fait tout simplement de d'avoir une
vie qui est beaucoup plus aisé est
facile et que forcément beaucoup plus
agréable
à voir qu'une vie où on va toujours se
battre pour payer le loyer cesse donc
c'est une chance extraordinaire nicolas
parti je vous ai déranger en pleine
création alors je vous laisse retourner
à vos pinceaux et à vos pastel merci
beaucoup merci bien
[Musique]